de la dépouillementelle permet
d'accompagner les familles réunionnaises
endoyer pas la perte d'un proche une
aide financière allant jusqu'à 5000
euros qui permet d'alléger les frais de
rapatriement qui sont onéreux
[Musique]
depuis 2022 pour faciliter les démarches
des familles endoyer par un décès hors
de Lille le département s'est engagé à
réhausser le plafond de l'aide au
rapatriement des dépôts
la des comprise entre 3000 et 5000 euros
en fonction des revenus allons à la
rencontre de Marie-Hélène qui a été
soutenue par le Département lors de ce
moment douloureux Benjamin Hélène
bonjour maronie comment le département
l'accompagne à Oullins dans ce moment
difficile que la période de ta fille
Jessica a 36 ans tu enlèves de l'antenne
de Paris j'aurais été un peu perdu quand
on arrive un cas comme ça on est perdu
nous-même personnellement et là j'ai eu
à faire par exemple madame
elle a occupé des papiers du rap à
patrimo du corps ben j'ai pu ramener ma
fille en même temps que je rentrais à la
Réunion donc on peut dire que le
département par le biais de l'antenne de
Paris qui a servi du département l'a
beaucoup aidao pas que financièrement
mais beaucoup dans les démarches
là on pense même plus à l'argent on
pense le retour du corps de ton enfant
avec toi et tous les papiers il faut de
l'aide pour les gens qui sont dans des
cas comme ça parce que on est perdu
suite à la création de la loi égalité
réelle d'outre-mer le département a mis
en place le dispositif qui permet de
prendre en charge une partie des frais
du rapatriement du corps depuis la
métropole bonjour firoise bonjour
maronie comment fonctionne ce dispositif
alors le dispositif d'aide
aurapatriement de l'épaule mortel du
département et là pour accompagner les
familles réunionnaises qui ont perdu un
proche parent qui est décédé donc en
dehors du territoire de La Réunion donc
les départements et là pour les aider
donc tant c'est le plan financier que
sur le plan aussi d'accompagnement
psychologique qui peut bénéficier de
cette année c'est l'ensemble des
familles bien sûr sous conditions de
ressources et sous certaines règles
administratives mais sinon l'ensemble
des personnes donc d'origine
réunionnaise peut bénéficier de ce
dispositif pour permettre justement qui
reste à charge moins important pour les
familles rayonnaises aujourd'hui l'aide
et plafonnée donc à 3000 euros ou à 5000
euros en fonction bien sûr les
conditions de ressources de la personne
qui est décédée et pour bénéficier de il
suffit que l'ensemble des personnes se
rapprochent des services du département
et notamment le service des
interventions qui s'occupent de cela on
va les accompagner dans toutes les
démarches dans avec toutes les pièces à
fournir comment bien l'antenne de Paris
l'antenne de Paris est un partenaire
privilégié quand il y a un décès dans le
cadre de transfert sanitaire ou même en
dehors de ce cadre-là et bien que
s'appuyer sur l'équipe de l'antenne de
Paris pour pouvoir faire en sorte de
t'accompagner dans les démarches de
pouvoir être en lien avec les
prestataires et là l'antenne est de
soutien logistique et psychologique très
important merci maronie
presque un soutien financier soit
dispositif apporte au bénéficiaire un
soutien moral l'implication des agents
du Département permet de soulager les
familles du défunt sur une grande partie
des démarches administratives
[Musique]
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur l'aide de
rapatriement des dépouillementaire
n'hésitez pas vous avez toutes les
coordonnées qui s'affichent sur votre
écran le département des générations
c'est fini vous souhaitez revoir cet
épisode ainsi que les épisodes
précédents rendez-vous sur notre site et
une réseaux sociaux quant à moi je vous
retrouve très vite pour un nouvel
épisode à bientôt
la semaine prochaine nous allons
découvrir le dispositif le prix d'oeuvre
d'artothèque a constitué une collection
depuis de 2000 oeuvres et ouvrages cette
exposition présente une vingtaine
d'oeuvres afin de partager sa vivacité
avec le public et met en lumière le
principe du prêt d'un
[Musique]